à Montréal le coup d'envoi de la
cinquième conférence internationale sur
le sida a été donné enfin l'après-midi
pour Montréal la conférence de l'été
dernier était une sorte de retour aux
sources la métropole avait déjà
accueilli l'événement en 1989
un moment historique au beau milieu de
ce rassemblement savant des groupes
d'appui aux principaux intéressés les
patients avaient envahi les lieux
[Applaudissements]
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'amis et on va en
perdre beaucoup d'eau et 7 ans que le
gouvernement s'enlève les doigts du
derrière et fasse quelque chose
à l'époque la maladie était souvent
tabou elle touchait essentiellement des
communautés marginalisées en premier
lieu des hommes homosexuels
c'est encore en partie vrai aujourd'hui
même si le virus peut infecter n'importe
qui en 2021 selon l'ONU sida plus de 38
millions de personnes vivaient avec le
VIH dans le monde cette année-là un
million et demi de nouvelles infections
ont été recensés
[Musique]
Sébastien Aumont lui a reçu le
diagnostic fin 2019 bienvenue chez moi
dans mon freak show comme j'avais
j'ai beaucoup de vinyles ma passion du
disque depuis que je suis tout petit
aspirant chanteur il habite un petit
appartement du village Guy à Montréal il
a grandi dans les années où le VIH
faisait des ravages dans la communauté
homosexuelle de son propre aveu il n'y
connaissait pas grand chose il se
protégeait mais à 34 ans il a attrapé
malgré tout
[Musique]
sur le coup quand tu reçois la nouvelle
tu penses je sauter là autant point de
vue personnel que ta santé que tes
relations professionnelles tout en
univers on devrait chambouler
on dirait qu'il y avait plus rien là
plus rien fait de sens puis là ce que je
continue à me battre encore plus
rendu là
[Musique]
pour Guy Henri Godin ce choc du
diagnostic remonte à loin
monsieur Gaudin est hémophile il œuvre
est semblablement été infecté lors d'une
transfusion sanguine dans les années 80
j'accuse tous les gouvernements
canadiens d'avoir tué de 3000 Canadiens
canadiennes par le VIH
avocat il a participé activement à
l'enquête publique qui a révélé dans les
années 90 que du sang contaminé avait
provoqué l'infection de milliers de
Canadiens par le VIH et le virus de
l'hépatite C aujourd'hui après de 60 ans
ces problèmes de santé s'accumulent je
vais vous montrer ma panoplie de
médicaments que j'apprends j'en ai
plusieurs parce que des maladies
secondaires associées au VIH quand on
vieillit comme le diabète des problèmes
cardiaques le plus important c'est
sûrement celui-ci c'est une trithérapie
c'est une fois par jour un comprimé une
seule fois par jour
à partir de la moitié des années 90 les
médicaments antirétroviraux ou
trithérapies ont permis de maîtriser le
virus une véritable révolution d'un
traitement du VIH
après s'être longuement demandé comment
et à qui parler de sa séropositivité
Sébastien s'est retrouvé sous les feux
de la rampe dans une télé-réalité axée
sur les rapports amoureux
de transparent avec toi tu as fait c'est
une émission ou
on rencontre des gens sur des dates donc
moi me présenter cette garçon j'en ai
choisi un pour faire l'aventure c'est
quand même assez récent dans ma vie
c'est pas tout le monde qui est au
courant mais chaque
comme pas le choix de dire à quelqu'un
que je pourrais peut-être fréquenter
ce qui se passe je suis séropositif
indétectable je sais pas si tu connais
un peu toute cet univers-là
donc
c'est ça je suis passé de personnes
laissées à tout le monde le sait c'est
un deuxième communion dans ma vie mais
devant des millions de personnes
grâce au traitement disponible
aujourd'hui Sébastien peut vivre
normalement avec une pilule par jour le
virus est indétectable dans son sang il
ne risque plus de le transmettre à
d'autres personnes
[Musique]
je gère très bien le médicament donc ma
santé à ce niveau là est pas mise en
danger du tout
je suis aussi diabétique mais contrôler
et c'est pour ma méthode de famille
c'est précis que le diabète est venu il
faut plus dangereux que le VIH donc
mesdames sont traités et les deux sont
stables donc
[Musique]
ceux qui ont accès à ces médicaments ne
meurent plus du sida et ils peuvent
aspirer à vivre aussi longtemps que
n'importe qui aussi longtemps mais pas
toujours aussi bien
les maladies liées au vieillissement les
douleurs sont plus présentes chez les
personnes qui vivent avec le VIH
c'est 85 30
ou 50 ans puis tu prends ça un peu
légèrement mais là quand tu vas voir 58
ans afin de l'été tu dises
je regarde puis je compte puis 12 à 15
médicaments différents
autour de moi c'est vraiment comme comme
ça que je me sens puis ben je trouve pas
ça drôle
[Musique]
il n'y a pas grand chose pour arrêter
monsieur Gaudin il trompe en quelque
sorte le destin en donnant tout ce qu'il
peut il siège entre autres sur des
comités qui évaluent les projets de
recherche sur le VIH au Canada et comme
patient il participe lui-même à
certaines études c'est quoi les
symptômes donc il faudrait que je me
méfie et si vous perdez beaucoup de
poids
il discute de l'étude VIH vieillissement
qui suit à long terme plusieurs
centaines de Canadiens qui avancent en
âge avec le VIH
rien depuis que le 50 on a tendance à
voir dans les études malheureusement là
c'est la survenue des comorbidités liées
au vieillissement environ une dizaine
d'années plus tôt juste comme ça ici ça
va être particulièrement aux maladies
cardiovasculaires plusieurs travaux
l'ont montré les infarctus sont plus
fréquents chez les personnes infectées
par le VIH
alors moi le cœur de ma recherche c'est
de découvrir pourquoi et de tenter de
trouver des stratégies de mitigation à
ça pour que les patients qui vivent avec
le VIH puissent réellement avoir une
espérance de vie normale en quantité en
longueur mais aussi en qualité
l'équipe fait passer des examens de
tomodensitométrie aux participants et
analyse les plaques qui se déposent avec
le temps dans leurs artères du cœur ce
qui peut les boucher et provoquer des
infarctus les chercheurs vérifient si
ces plaques d'athérosclérose sont plus
fréquentes chez les patients qui ont le
VIH mais aussi de quel type de plaques
il s'agit
les participants qui vivent avec le VIH
ont plus tendance à avoir des plaques
coronariennes qui ne contiennent pas de
calcium ce sont des plaques qui sont
plus molles ce sont des plaques qui sont
perçues comme étant plus vulnérables ou
plus fragiles donc on pense que les
plaques des patients VIH sont des
plaques qui sont plus à risque de mener
à des infarctus
pourquoi une telle différence plusieurs
facteurs entrent en ligne de compte les
médicaments antirétroviraux peuvent à la
longue fatiguer l'organisme le virus
lui-même affaiblit le système
immunitaire qui contribue à nous
protéger contre les maladies
cardiovasculaires
vieillir avec le VIH c'est un phénomène
qui est formidablement intéressant
excusez-moi de le nommer comme ça parce
que c'est un réel cancer d'essayer de
trouver toutes les causes qui mènent un
vieillissement prématuré chez ses
patients là
les facteurs sociaux aussi doivent être
prises en compte le VIH touche toujours
de manière disproportionnée les membres
les plus vulnérables de nos sociétés les
tabous sont tenaces
[Musique]
Jean-Robert aux toiles sida depuis les
tous débuts la première fois qu'il l'a
vu c'était chez un de ses patients au
début des années 80 avant même que la
maladie apparaisse sur le radar de la
communauté médicale au début pour
roissyder ça voulait dire visite au
salon funéral puis explications aux
familles pendant des décennies il a
couru les congrès spécialistes siégé à
des comités contribués aux politiques
qui ont façonné la réponse à l'épidémie
à 83 ans il lutte toujours à sa manière
auprès des plus vulnérables les Poké
comme il les appelle
du bien et c'est ce plaisir-là de
soigner des gens qui ont une
reconnaissance incroyable
j'ai déjeuné guide ça j'ai déjà à
l'envers depuis près de 60 ans qu'il
exerce la médecine sa stratégie est
toujours la même aller au devant des
gens entendre leurs besoins pour mieux
les soigner de la médecine communautaire
comme il tient à la nommer s'il y avait
pas ça évidemment
une machine après screen et c'est sûr
qu'il me fait du bien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est dans un centre de
désintoxication des Laurentides qu'il va
les rencontrer
avec son équipe infirmière intervenants
il propose sur place des consultations
tests de dépistage et traitement
qu'est-ce qu'on va aller faire
semblant de travailler parfait
les gens qui sont ici sont peu enclins à
fréquenter le système de santé pourtant
leurs habitudes certains sont des
utilisateurs de drogue par exemple
augmentent le risque de contracter des
infections comme le VIH le rôle de la
santé communautaire c'est de vous de
vous accompagner que vous êtes bien
protégé contre les VIH
docteur Robert leur parle de la prép la
prophylaxie pré-exposition c'est encore
méconnu mais de nos jours les mêmes
médicaments qui servent à traiter le VIH
chez les gens infectés peuvent prévenir
la contamination par le virus avec une
efficacité qui peut atteindre 99%
. on a un vaccin entre la bouche
puisqu'il fait qu'on a une bonne
concentration extrêmement efficace dans
le sang très rapidement qui fait que si
on rencontre le virus le virus
s'implante pas on le bloque
alors c'est notre dépanneur ça c'est
très important Robert et son équipe ont
pignon sur rue en région à Saint-Jérôme
dans leur dispensaire la prévention
passe par la distribution de matériel
alors oui
ça c'est pour les snifs ça c'est pour le
GHB
aussi a toujours avec des Condens
le mot d'ordre ici ne jamais juger en
matière de VIH le risque côtoie souvent
la marginalité
toxicomanie travail du sexe et la
discrimination qu'il accompagne
des mois sinon des années à part de
vivre avec
cette cicatrice
c'est le rejet
omniprésent
et perfide ils ont besoin d'aide parce
que c'est hallucinant la souffrance qui
dit ici
[Musique]
au cours des dernières années le Canada
a enregistré globalement une légère
baisse des nouvelles infections par le
VIH mais dans certains groupes elles
augmentent toujours notamment chez les
femmes et les autochtones de respecter
appartient aux deux catégories
ancienne actrice elle est originaire du
Nil du lac Huron en Ontario et vit dans
la région de Montréal dans les années 90
elle a fait la tournée des théâtres du
pays et au-delà sous le pseudonyme de
Doris linkleter elle a incarné des rôles
célèbres de la dramaturgie autochtone
au début des années 2000 elle a appris
qu'elle avait le sida
à l'époque il y avait beaucoup de
stigmatisation des gens étaient bannis
par leurs conseils de bande
[Musique]
si vous vouliez rentrer chez vous avec
le VIH
la communauté ne voulait pas de vous
je suis retourné chez moi et je me suis
dit ok ils vont avoir peur mais vous
savez quoi
je vais me tenir debout
[Musique]
après avoir cru mourir de respecter ses
soigné et a pris du mieux puis sa
maladie est devenue son moteur
ça a déclenché un processus où je me
suis mise à voir le chemin qui m'avait
mené là
à partir de ce moment elle constate que
les services destinés aux femmes
autochtones qui vivent avec le VIH sont
rares elle va alors multiplier les
occasions d'incarner un rôle inédit pour
elle le sien partagez sa propre histoire
en guise de thérapie
j'ai commencé à parler des abus sexuels
que j'ai subi enfin
raconté mon histoire
et les mauvais traumatismes qui ont mené
au diagnostic de VIH
ça fait partie de la guérison
dans ma langue on appelle ça une bonne
vie j'ai trouvé comment y arriver
et maintenant je vais aider les autres
ailles parvenir
[Musique]
salut ma belle Isabelle
accompagner les autres c'est aussi la
mission de Jean-Robert dans sa clinique
en matière de prévention chaque petit
pas est une victoire
comment vont tes
elle a vécu dans la rue a fait le
trottoir on lui a retiré la garde de ses
enfants aujourd'hui elle y voit
régulièrement elle a un travail une
voiture ça peut paraître peu mais pour
elle c'est déjà beaucoup
les clients bienvenue j'en fais plus
finalement c'est des clients réguliers
mais je pense qu'ils vont pas y arriver
mais je ne fais que pareil quand
quelqu'un est encore en vie vous avez
gagné
ça
bagnole oh oui j'ai cédé
20 ans après son diagnostic Doris
Peltier ne foule plus les planches de
théâtre désormais chercheuse à
l'Université McMaster elle mène des
travaux auprès des femmes autochtones
atteintes du VIH dans un hôtel près de
saskatum une soixantaine d'entre elles
se rassemble
[Musique]
ou visualiser la santé à interroger des
femmes séropositives sur ce qui les
aidaient à rester en santé en
particulier en lien avec la culture et
les traditions autochtones
les femmes qui sont ici ne combattent
pas que le VIH
toxicomanie abus violence souvent le
virus et la moindre de leurs difficultés
les inégalités
le manque d'accès aux soins la pauvreté
combien de fois les femmes doivent-elles
raconter ce qui leur arrive
et pourtant rien n'est fait
[Musique]
la démarche des chercheuses devient
alors une forme de thérapie les
rencontres font avancer non seulement
les connaissances mais les femmes
elles-mêmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans un autre projet entre le début et
la fin de l'enquête la consommation de
drogues et les taux d'incarcération
avait diminué chez les participantes
alors que la prise d'antirétroviraux
avait augmenté
nous voulions créer un espace où les
femmes pourraient trouver de la force
tout en participant à nos recherches
en se tournant vers la culture et les
coutumes autochtones Pelletier croit que
ces femmes peuvent retrouver un
sentiment d'appartenance une estime
d'elle-même favorable à leur santé
[Musique]
nous ne pensons pas qu'ici nous pensons
aussi avec le coeur c'est plus
holistique
c'est pourquoi ça aide d'intégrer ces
approches globales dans notre façon de
mener nos recherches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
André Morneau ne connaissait rien du VIH
quand il l'a attrapé j'ai eu
je suis bien renseigné
il lui a fallu 5 ans pour se faire à
l'idée
les cinq premières années j'avais pas
besoin de médicaments
j'ai commencé à prendre la musculation
monsieur Morneau
a joué quelques années plus tard une
autre maladie a atteint son foie
aujourd'hui à seulement 54 ans il se
sait condamné
sur les poumons je fais de la suite de
l'eau dans le corps
j'ai eu des étourdissements j'ai des
Bleus partout et c'est de plus en plus
fréquent
serait malgré tout il a fait un choix
inhabituel
[Musique]
ma vie est finie
comme ça
[Musique]
vous continuez à faire tous les jours
vous êtes prêt aussi à participer à
l'étude
André Morneau a discuté de cette ultime
don avec son médecin Bertrand le boucher
dirige d'ailleurs des travaux sur
l'implication des personnes qui vivent
avec le VIH dans la recherche souvent
ils sont victimes dans le sens où
quelqu'un leur a transmis le VIH et ils
veulent en faire une une ils veulent
transformer ça une espèce d'expérience
positive il y a eu plusieurs personnes
déjà qui l'ont fait aux États-Unis au
Canada et ils le disent bien c'est
important ils arrivent même à donner une
signification alors à leur mort en
disant même après la mort je veux
continuer à aider et ça je trouve que ça
ça force le respect en fait
l'autre facteur limitant est sur lequel
on n'a pas de contrôle c'est le délai
entre le décès et l'autopsit parce que
ici aussi la décision d'André mornou est
traitée avec le plus grand respect grâce
à ce don l'équipe de Nicolas Chaumont va
pouvoir approfondir ses travaux sur les
réservoirs du VIH
malgré la trithérapie on ne guérit
toujours pas du virus il peut revenir en
force si les patients arrêtent leur
traitement c'est donc qu'il survit latin
quelque part dans l'organisme ce qu'on
appelle les réservoirs du VIH c'est les
cellules et les tissus dans lesquels le
VIH se cache chez les patients qui
prennent une trithérapie on sait que la
trithérapie bloque la réplication du
virus mais elle élimine pas complètement
le virus et la raison pour laquelle elle
élimine pas parce que le virus reste
caché dans ses fichiers c'est celui
les experts ont notamment trouvé ces
virus cachés dans le sang le VIH infecte
des cellules du système immunitaire et
peu y persister ils n'ont pas trouvé
toute l'explication ces dernières années
ils ont poussé leurs recherches plus
loin ils ont pu étudier les organes de
deux hommes atteints du VIH qui avait
demandé l'aide médicale à mourir
[Musique]
alors la raison pour laquelle on fait ça
c'est parce que on pense que la majorité
du virus du VIH se cache dans les tissus
profonds donc en fait cette opportunité
d'aller chercher sur les réservoirs
c'est l'unique façon en fait d'aller
comprendre exactement ce qui se passe
dans ces tissus donc je vous montre
parce qu'on parle de la logistique pour
le troisième patient
avant le décès du donneur la tension
monte la récupération et l'analyse de
ces tissus après le Topsy doivent se
faire rapidement
il faut beaucoup de monde pourquoi parce
que on collecte 20 30 tissus différents
et pour chacun de ces tissus on a
beaucoup de choses à faire si on veut
les préparer pour qu'après ils soient
exploitables pour nos travaux de
recherche je vous rappelle que on voit
travailler sur des cellules vivantes
directement isolées du patient donc là
faudra aller vite évidemment parce qu'on
veut pas qu'elle m'a entre temps les
tissus qui abritent le système
immunitaire mais aussi le foie les
poumons le cerveau seront analysés
c'est une course contre la montre parce
que quand le tissu est coupé
il meurt ce qui est normal donc il faut
aller les cellules qui me constituent
meurent avec le VIH un virus qui produit
de l'ARN ça ça se préserve en dehors de
quelques heures après le décès quand il
infecte des cellules du système
immunitaire le VIH copie son matériel
génétique son ARN en ADN l'ADN va
ensuite s'intégrer au noyau des cellules
de là de nouveaux ARN seront produits
pour former de nouveaux virus
ce qui intéresse particulièrement les
chercheurs ce sont les virus dit intacte
chaque fois que le VIH copie son code
génétique il fait des erreurs beaucoup
de ses copies sont défectueuses mais pas
toutes
parmi toutes les réservoirs
de toutes les provirus qui persistent
qui sont intactes et c'est les intacts
qui vont être responsables d'un retour
de la charge virale si arrête leur
traitement donc c'est vraiment ce qu'on
veut cibler si on veut guérir les gens
et ça c'est pas il y en a dessus
beaucoup dans le cas OK dans la
circulation il y en a plus il y en a de
moins il y en a aussi un peu partout
sauf c'est pas
en séquençant les génomes complets des
virus retrouvés dans les organes des
donneurs Caroline Dufour établit une
sorte d'organigramme génétique du virus
ça lui permet de mettre en relation ces
différentes séquences génétiques à
travers le corps et ses réservoirs une
fois que le réservoir est établi est-ce
qu'il reste juste séquestrer dans un
organe ou est-ce qu'il y a une espèce de
connectivité entre les organes malgré
tout
conclusion les mêmes séquences de virus
se retrouvent à différents endroits du
corps en particulier dans des tissus où
se concentrent les cellules immunitaires
comme les ganglions et la rate
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
probablement dire que les cellules
infectées par le VIH voyage donc c'est à
dire qu'elles sont capables d'aller d'un
organe à l'autre donc ça donne une image
du réservoir qui est finalement beaucoup
plus dynamique que ce qu'on pensait les
virus ou plutôt les cellules qui
abrivent être les virus bougent bougent
beaucoup bouge tout le temps et ça en
fait c'est une belle opportunité pour
nous pour aller les attaquer parce que
si jamais ça bouge et ça change
d'organes ça veut dire qu'à un moment
ils vont devenir plus visible que cacher
au tréfond de ses organes
attaquer les réservoirs du VIH pour
l'éradiquer une bonne fois pour toute
c'est ce qui motive chaque jour Andrès
finici a se lever à l'aube pour partir
au labo il faut dire que l'intérêt du
virologue remonte à loin quand j'étais
tout petit
et jeunes enfants qui étaient infectés
par le VIH puis il y avait absolument
rien à faire c'est une nouvelle maladie
absolument rien faire c'est d'avoir
marqué et la transmis cette marque un
peu jusqu'à moi puis c'est depuis ces
moments-là j'ai toujours voulu
travailler sur le sur les virus du sida
puis je fais toujours ça
[Musique]
il y a encore du pain sur la planche en
40 ans de recherche aucun traitement n'a
réussi à éliminer complètement le virus
et aucun vaccin ne s'est avéré efficace
pour prévenir l'infection de manière
durable c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
personnes qui n'ont pas essayé là c'est
parce que c'est un virus qui est
particulièrement difficile et je pense
qu'on a la responsabilité de faire le
maximum qu'on peut
le VIH est un adversaire coriace d'abord
il mute souvent les molécules à sa
surface changent si bien que nos
anticorps ont du mal à les reconnaître
pour s'y attacher ces protéines de
surface servent de clés ou virus pour
infecter des cellules de notre système
immunitaire les lymphocytes TCD4 il
affaiblit donc en priorité les cellules
même qui sont censées le combattre et
puis recréer en laboratoire des parties
de virus que nos anticorps puissent
reconnaître pour en faire un vaccin par
exemple c'est avéré hautement complexe
c'est un défi particulier là donc c'est
s'il y a pas de vaccin c'est pas parce
que les chercheurs ont pas cherché
[Musique]
avec ses collègues Andrés financy
cherche des vaccins potentiels mais
aussi des traitements contre le VIH il
croit avoir trouvé un moyen de
contourner certaines de ses astuces
une façon d'exposer les cellules
infectées au système immunitaire pour
qu'ils puissent les cibler efficacement
et s'en débarrasser
grâce à une petite molécule qui force
les protéines de surface du virus à
s'ouvrir
la clé d'entrée du virus sur ce que je
travaille c'est une sorte de fleurs à
trois pétales l'extérieur et bien
invisible mais par contre si on joue un
tout petit peu l'intérieur ça reste
immunitaire est capable de le voir
pour l'instant ça fonctionne chez les
souris elle n'élimine pas encore
complètement le virus mais il met plus
de temps à revenir après l'arrêt du
traitement
de quoi entrevoir un moyen d'éliminer
ces fameux réservoirs cachés
[Musique]
des derniers moments le plus sereinement
possible
et vous sentez prêt à partir oui
André Morneau n'aura pas le temps de
voir le fruit de toutes ces recherches
ces derniers mois sa maladie du foie a
progressé
[Musique]
les médicaments ne font plus vraiment
fait donc devient difficile à vivre puis
avant de devenir complètement confus et
dément je m'en vais
cet automne s'entend la fin approchée il
a demandé à recevoir l'aide médicale à
mourir j'ai eu fait tout ce que je
pouvais faire
mes médecins les lacorde de maintien en
tant que tout ce qui était possible il y
a de faire pour que je demeure vivant et
quand le résultat est synonyme c'est
impossible qu'on t'offre la possibilité
de choisir de partir dignement
n'a laissé un peu difficile à prendre
n'hésite pas à faire ça
mais il partira en sachant qu'il
contribue lui aussi à la lutte contre le
virus du sida
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ambiance fébrile l'été dernier à
Montréal
[Musique]
des milliers de personnes chercheurs
patients militants sont réunis pour la
conférence internationale sur le
sidables en coulisses Doris Pelletier se
concentre
j'ai été un peu nerveuse ce matin
terrifié même elle est invitée à lancer
la deuxième journée des changes sur la
plus grande scène du Congrès
il y a 5000 places je devrais être
habitué
comme actrice j'ai joué devant des
grandes salles
alors on y va
une occasion unique de parler des
besoins grandissant des populations
autochtones en matière de VIH non
seulement ici mais ailleurs aussi
[Applaudissements]
je vais continuer à en parler
je siège à un comité aviseur de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
une de mes recommandations
et de reconnaître les Premières nations
comme des populations prioritaires dans
tous les pays où vivent des autochtones
nous sommes en retard et nous n'allons
pas atteindre les cibles mondiales
dans l'espoir d'endiguer l'épidémie de
VIH SIDA les Nations Unies se sont
fixées des objectifs la cible 95 que
d'ici 2030 95% des personnes infectées
connaissent leur état que 95% de ces
personnes atteintes reçoivent un
traitement d'anti-rétrouviraux et que
95% de ses patients traités est une
charge virale indétectable
mais en 2021 dans le monde on en était
encore loin
[Musique]
et la pandémie de covid-19 n'a pas aidé
l'effet de la covid sur la pandémie de
VIH a été assez désastreux on a perdu en
dépistage on a perdu en accès au
traitement ce qui fait qu'en fait le
nombre d'infections augmente et on
apprenant perdu 5 à 10 ans en fait de
lutte contre le VIH au niveau mondial à
cause de la covid-19
les chercheurs
premiers congrès en présentiel depuis
2020 était aussi une occasion de
mobiliser les troupes toute l'expertise
de recherche VIH a été beaucoup
sollicitée pour l'expertise de recherche
covid qui était à construire et puis ce
sont des expertises avec beaucoup de
chevauchement donc il y a une urgence
particulière en VIH de se retrouver et
se recentrer sur le VIH reprendre le
flambeau pour ce combat là on a appris
énormément mais on ne comprend pas
encore parfaitement comment les virus
fonctionnent ou les virus s'écachent
notamment il faut éradiquer quel virus
mais encore faut-il les trouver il y a
quand même des progrès entre autres dans
le domaine crucial des vaccins de
nouvelles approches sont à l'essai par
exemple celle de l'ARN messager la même
technologie qui a permis de produire
rapidement les premiers vaccins contre
la covid-19
il y a des études qu'on a rendu public
qui montre qu'on peut dans un modèle
animal prévenir l'infection avec ce type
de vaccins c'est un vaccin qui a
plusieurs étapes qui est compliqué mais
c'est une c'est porteur d'espoir il y a
un corps des étapes à parcourir mais je
pense que c'est c'est ça
outre lueur d'espoir une poignée de cas
de guérison du VIH ont été rapportés ces
dernières années des gens qui se sont
débarrassés du virus sans qu'on
comprenne encore bien commun
[Musique]
des gens qui vivaient avec le village
pendant 10 20 ans et chez qui
aujourd'hui il y a plus du tout de
traces de virus il y a encore beaucoup
de travail pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui est commun à ces gens-là et surtout
le plus important c'est comment est-ce
qu'on peut le reproduire chez tout le
monde trouver une guérison pour le VIH
c'est pas s'amuser à trouver quelque
chose de mieux que la trithérapie juste
pour le fun c'est important parce que
c'est une pandémie qui infecte encore
chaque année des millions de personnes
qui tuent encore chaque année des
centaines de milliers de personnes et le
nombre de personnes qui avec le VIH
continue d'augmenter contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser
[Musique]
c'est bien ce qui motive encore Guy
Henri Godin a s'impliquer
malgré les problèmes de santé qui
s'accumulent ils siègent sur diversités
et participent à la formation des futurs
soignants pour les sensibiliser aux
réalités des personnes qui vivent avec
le VIH
qu'est-ce qui me donne de la drive ben
je me dis je me lève le matin puis je me
demande tout le temps je peux te faire
une différence qu'est-ce que je peux
faire de plus il y a des médicaments
qu'on évalue il y a trois quatre ans qui
sont devenus de la prep puis exposer
quand tu vois ça ben c'est c'est très
valorisant
et comme il faut parfois relâcher la
pression il s'implique aussi à fond dans
une autre passion moi c'est mon équipe à
la vie à la mort
initiales le GHG qui Henri Godin mais ça
fait
comme moi je suis né pour la 1000
canadien puis ma mère m'a pas donné le
choix je pense pas juste à l'hémophilie
je pense pas juste au droit je pense pas
juste ça au VIH puis aussi DOP à
l'hépatite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
après avoir broyé du noir au moment de
recevoir son diagnostic de VIH puis
hésiter à le révéler il multiplie
aujourd'hui les projets nouvelle chanson
nouvelle apparition dans une émission de
variété aussi
plein de joie d'amour aussi revenu dans
ma vie dans mon cœur mettons ça m'a
vraiment donné l'expression de terminer
cette chanson là sous un nouvel angle
plus positif pierre rempli d'espoir
comme une mélodie à travers tout ça le
VIH prend de moins en moins de place
dans sa vie bonjour tout le monde je
m'appelle Seb et je vous souhaite la
bienvenue à ce nouvel épisode de place à
la musique c'est toujours présent parce
que je continue d'en parler je continue
d'éduquer si je peux dire une certaine
façon que c'est vraiment beau comment tu
parles de ce sujet-là de manière à
l'époque je le faisais pour mon
homosexualité puis avec les années
j'avais pu vraiment besoin d'en parler
peut-être qu'un jour ça va être chaud
aussi avec le VIH
je cherchais la lumière d'ici là c'est à
son tour de s'engager dans la lutte
contre le virus mais surtout pour ceux
qui vivent avec lui c'est pas par quel
miracle mais je pense j'ai réussi à
prendre toute sa négatif là puis assez
d'enfer de quoi te positif et
je peux pas croire que j'aurais passé à
côté de tout ce qui m'arrive en ce
moment si j'avais décidé de prendre
cette option là de d'en finir
j'aurais vraiment pensé à côté de
quelque chose
[Musique]
de ta symphonie
renaître mes sens